how did you feel when you saw the op-ed
for the first time
objection asked and answered just now
i my prior question was about his
reaction all right i'll allow it
hurts
yeah a blinding um
a blinding
hurt it was
it was like somebody hit me in the back
of the head with a two by four i um
and
as it said i had no
i had no ability to speak prior to
because
even if i had done an interview to try
to explain myself
it turned into a hit piece
so
my mouth was
shut
and this was the opportunity where i
thought
it
something's got to be done
this guy's just got to be done
i couldn't take it anymore
mr deb how did you feel when you learned
that
you were being dropped from the pirates
of the caribbean franchise
um
well it was
the pirates of the caribbean franchise
um
it was
the character that
captain jack sparrow was a character
that i had
built from the ground up
um
with something that i
i've
i've
of course put a lot of
my as you do with all characters but you
put a lot of yourself
into the characters so
and
also
having
worked on
these films with these people and
having added
much of myself much of my own
rewriting of the dialogue and
scenes and the jokes and whatever they
are
i didn't quite understand
how
that after that long relationship and
quite a successful
relationship certainly for disney
um that
they would
but suddenly i was
guilty until proven innocent
mr deb what was your intention with
respect to future pirates movies
aside from what you'd been asked to do
my feeling was that
these characters
should be able to
have their proper
goodbye
as it were
a franchise can only last for so long
um
and
um
there's a way to end
a franchise like that and i thought that
the characters
deserved to
to have their
their way out of
to to end the
the franchise on a
on a
very good note i planned on continuing i
until it was time to stop
mr deb
last week mr rottenborn asked you about
a quote where you said you wouldn't come
back to the pirates franchise for 300
million dollars in a million alpacas do
you remember that
i do
when relative to learning that you would
no longer be a part of the pirates
franchise did you make that statement
i think long before i
made the statement
there was
a very
deep and distinct sense of having been
betrayed
by
the people that i had
been working with the people that i had
worked hard for
the people that i delivered a character
to
that they initially despised but somehow
um
you know even i stuck to my guns with
the character and it seemed to work
so
um
do you recall when specifically you made
that statement about the 300 million
dollars and the 100 alpacas objection
asked an answer
i believe i made that statement during a
press conference in the san sebastian
film at the san sebastian film festival
when i was
i was asked about
my um
well situation
and what year would that have been if
you can recall believe it was last year
or so
mr bedley and i had
we'd met
um while i was making a film called the
tourist in in venice
and we were
it was an instant connection he's he's
born and bred in the uk and uh has a
that
english
uh
sort of dry
kind of obtuse abstract sense of humor
and that was one of the things that we
connected on is
how would you describe mr betney's
relationship with miss hurd while you
and miss heard were together
abominable
why was that
um
ms heard despised
mr putney
because
mainly because we had become such close
friends
and
for her he was a threat
um
and would
take me away from her
in with regard to
if paul bentley was getting the
attention from me
that was a showstopper it would it would
cause
all kinds of um
unpleasant trees
to the point of where
when we were on the island
with mr putney
his wife and his
four children
um
[Music]
ms hurd and mr betany
got into
some debate
over lunch
and
i just remember that
whenever mr benny tried to make a point
she would talk over him and then it
started to get quite rude
she got
she got mean
and she got loud
and then his
i believe it was his
18 year old boy
who was
he was he was getting ready to go to a
really he's a very bright bright
brilliant
kid
he entered the uh conversation
because this was something to do with
what he'd studied in school and he knew
quite a lot about it and he voiced his
opinion
and
uh
miser demeaned that young man
to the point of where he where he
he burst into uh
tears
and
walked away
um
and it was at that point
that
i had spoken to misheard and said that's
that's just unacceptable
that behavior is unacceptable
you have no right
to to to to demean that boy to
you cannot
always be right you should try being
wrong sometime because you might learn
something
and then um
i asked her
i asked her to
i thought it was best that she leave
now mr depp you said that
you did not write this portion that's in
red here that says
carly
simon said it call carly simon she said
it better babe is that right yes no
that's that's not mine
um
how do you know that it was misheard
that wrote that
objection lack of foundation a rule
though we can answer it
there are um
it's
well first it doesn't it looks like it's
trying to match my handwriting but my
handwriting is a lot more
of a scribble
and
why are you apologizing to dr kipper in
this message
i believe that um
at that point in in my
brain and in my life and in my heart i
was um
[Music]
completely
and utterly frustrated with
how i had to
how i was living my life and i had had
some
disagreement
with
dr kipper
and i was
i was
apologizing to him for having um
gone against his uh his wishes
or gone against his
advice let's say
what did you mean when you said i have
chopped off my left middle finger as a
reminder that i should never cut off cut
my right finger off again
it's again it's my way of dealing with
dealing with a painful situation it's
it's my way of dealing with a painful
situation where i resort to humor
so
i had lost the tip of my
right finger
and so i'm saying to him
i've now cut off my left finger
to remind me never to cut my right
finger off again
that's
that's not
i mean
when you say i got my finger cut off or
i cut my finger off or this or that it
doesn't necessarily mean that you did it
yourself and again
i'm a guitarist and have been since i
was 12 and that was the only
piece that i
found in my life at the age of 12
where
i knew
what i
i knew who
i could
that i could
escape into
music
and learn music and
the last thing
i'm a guitar i mean i
i still play the guitar with it's still
my first love
aside from my children it's
still my first love
there's
no reason in the world why i
literally
would cut my own
finger off to ruin
this this beautiful
opportunity that i was given at 12 to
learn how to play the guitar
um
and and and
um
again
why would i
start lopping off digits in my 50s
i've chopped my finger off it's like
saying you know i
i i
bumped into a knife uh
or something you know
it's it's it's not
i'm not admitting i think if i was going
to admit to someone that i actually
chopped my finger off
this text wouldn't be as it is i think
it would have been a long explanation as
to why i got to that point
but uh
no i can't take responsibility for
what i now call little richard my
chopped finger
when i went to the doctor
the emergency room i lied to them
because i didn't
i didn't
i didn't think it was
to
cause
a ruckus
implicate misheard
and then have
8 million stories
out in the press about
how she'd thrown a bottle of vodka at my
at me and it smashed
the
all the bones in the tip of my finger
and
cut off
about what was all sliced down through
you've seen the pictures
it was pretty horrible
it's been going on too long
we just gotta stop this
it's gonna stop
i don't know how to get my um reputation
back
[Music]
we write a letter together
[Music]
saying that we're going to take this out
of the public eye
[Music]
saying that we're trying to work this
out on our own
saying
that the media has created
such a [ __ ] hateful storm
that it's sickening
that we love each other
and that we want to make sure each other
is okay
have we had fights in the past have we
had this or whatever
they already know that don't matter
here's the deal no it matters
i have been
i am that you have no idea every ounce
of my credibility
has been taken from i mean and gun stone
is dishonest right
you know
the abuse and the abuse thing is is is
we've got to deal with that yeah
we've got to deal with that anyway of my
credit is my credibility you know what i
mean why did you put that out there
i did not you hurt me your team forces
you by going on the offensive i didn't
force you to start
i promise
look up the timeline for these things
everything is
forget
[Music]
let me talk to the [ __ ] team i did
not call the cops
i o called the cops
you told i will call the cops
i did not call the cops and i did not
give them any statement when they came
i've been trying to protect
oh i'm sorry i'm sorry because the last
time that it got crazy between us i
really did think i was gonna lose my
life and i thought you would do it on
accident
and i told you that
i said oh my god i thought the first
time but i lost a [ __ ] finger man
come on
i had a [ __ ] i had a
tell the world johnny tell them johnny
depp i joined up man i'm i'm a victim of
domestic violence and i you know it's a
fair fight it seems how many people
believe or side with you
it doesn't matter if you're verified my
ass would you know exactly be controlled
mr deb when did you have the
conversation reflected in this recording
with miss heard
i don't recall exactly when it was
what's your best estimate
my best estimate
is that it was um
before
long before the
while quite a while before the meeting
in san francisco in july
excuse me
how far after may 21st 2016 do you think
that conversation was
objection calls for speculation sorry he
said
i'm asking for his best estimate allowed
if you can answer it this way
so could you ask it again i was
distracted how long after may 21st 2016
do you believe that conversation took
place
i would i would say there was uh
not
too far maybe
a couple of months it was far enough to
where
the
the world media
was already bombarding me
so
um
it was
it was an attempt to try to
next question
what are you referring to when you said
you and miss heard will write a letter
together
i was trying to make a peaceful
settlement
and what are you referring to when you
say you lost a finger
a very large bottle of vodka severing my
index of my middle finger
in australia
and what were you referring to when you
said a can of mineral spirits was thrown
at your nose
one of the uh
arguments on the island where miss heard
had
been howling
at me with some argument and um
she picked up a can of
mineral spirits about yay big and
just
heaved it at me and it
struck me
on the bridge of the nose
and the right there you know the
forehead
and what did you say in response when
miss heard said tell the world johnny
tell them johnny depp i johnny depp a
man
i'm a victim too of domestic violence
i said yes i am